>> I'm Matt Kind from Scotland.
>> I'm Ramir.
I'm from Sri Lanka.
>> I'm a very young activist and I'm hoping
to change the world.
>> We're here at the world economic forum
to give, uh, the voice of
the youth, the younger generation and what
I think how chief companies
and individuals can do to make the world a
better place is that they
can think about things that they most cared
about when they were youth
like us and then put that into perspective
and actually be the
difference that they want the world to see.
>> And I believe that the best thing is that
countries should start
thinking about gay and lesbian attitudes in
a way that's not
prejudice, that's not discriminatory, and
start seeing them as people
and a natural part of human condition and
also to stop discriminating
against HIV positive people because there's
a lot of that goes on.
So that's us.
Bye, Egypt.
>> See ya.